writer director James Gunn has described
his easter-egg obsession as insane and
for guardians of the galaxy volume 2
gunner said that he worked extra hard to
sneak even more weird and wonderful
Easter eggs into the movie they need it
in the first one you became if you love
is it's Jan here and if you've seen
Guardians volume 2 now you'll know there
are plenty of Easter eggs MCU references
and in jokes that even casual viewers
will have noticed but in this video I
want to take a look at ten of the
coolest Easter eggs you might have
missed or which only hardcore fans will
have spotted if you want to let me know
any other juice or particularly enjoyed
just leave a comment below and make sure
you're also subscribed to be entered
into my awesome guardians of the galaxy
giveaway of course spoilers lie ahead
for guardians of the galaxy vol 2 so if
you haven't seen the movie yet you can
tap in the top right of the screen for
my spoiler free review and come back
here after you've seen the movie during
one of the Jumpgate scenes when yondu
rocket and Groot are traveling to egos
planets you no doubt thought his Stan
Lee's brilliant cameo with a group of
Watchers but there's a blink in your
miss it moment during an earlier
sequence when yondu ships streaked cast
a rocky planets were - aliens seem to be
duking it out you'll need to watch the
scene very carefully to spot that the
aliens are a pair of Cronin's we last
saw a cronin as part of the Marauders
who attacked vanaheim in saw the dark
world Thor defeated the Crone and easily
with his hammer in that movie but we're
definitely seeing more Krohn and soon in
the MCU is thor ragnarok directed - ytt
revealed here we playing the part of
Korg in the third Thor movie in the
comics the Cronin stone man core was
enslaved together with a hulk on the
planet sakaar
by the way there's another cool Thor
Ragnarok teased in the movie which I'll
reveal later volume to delve deeper into
nebula and gomorrah's backstory and the
abuse they suffered at the hands of
their adoptive father Stan off in the
scene after nebula and Gamora fight
nebula gives an erisa ket's the nation
of how far off punished her every time
she lost when he sets her and Gamora
against each other for example he pulled
her eye from her head her brain from her
skull and her arm from her body as well
as being a devastating part of nebulas
backstory in the movie this is actually
also an easter egg - a moment in the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline in the
comics where Sana's torches nebula after
he discovers that she pretended to be
his granddaughter
punishment Sanaa wreaks havoc on nebulas
body before presenting her to mistress
death who he wishes to impress Sylvester
Stalone makes a small but important
appearance in volume 2 setting himself
up in the mid credit scene as the leader
of a new team of ravages who will
probably see in the next Guardians movie
the team he's forming is a not the
original guardians of the galaxy team in
the comics and I've got an in-depth
video on sukar's new team which are
linked to in the video description below
for what you might have missed earlier
in the movie was a neat Easter egg pista
cars comic book origins during the scene
on the planet contracts EO once the car
is arguing with yondu about exiling him
from the Ravager clan for breaking their
code by trafficking children because
yondu that the colors that mo gorge will
not flash over your grave Oh gorgeous to
cast surname which he was given in the
comics after he was adopted as a baby by
a rebel leader called oh gawd
the cause words of course also
foreshadowed on do sad but heroic deaths
at the end of the movie after which the
ravages returned to honor their fallen
comrade releasing the colors no good
during your induced funeral in the scene
where ego is teaching Peter quill about
his celestial powers ego taps Peter in
the middle of his forehead which
reminded me of the ancient one dr.
strange and the idea of the third eye in
the MCU last film but the point I want
to focus on here is that we see Peters
eyes fill with black then little lights
and what look like planets and stars
appear in his eyes as well as this
happens Peter whispers the words I can
see it eternity this scene is a nod to
the comic book character eternity whose
body is a kind of Galaxy star silhouette
and who also has black eyes with a star
in the middle interestingly in the
comics eternity appears in multiple
storylines with Doctor Strange as well
as the infinity war Infinity Gauntlet
and infinity watch storylines talking of
eyes is a great callback to a joke from
the first guardians movie in the scene
where you on during rocket are locked up
after the Ravager mutiny
yondu asked baby Groot to get his
prototypes in from the captain's
quarters but Groot brings back a variety
of weird items including yondu's
Underpants for squealing or lonely
creature and a mechanical eye in the
first film as the guardians prepared to
face off against Ronan Rocket pretended
he needed one of the ravages mechanical
to complete the plan star-lord realized
that rocket was goofing around and
refused him but in this scene in volume
2 rocket finally got his wish and found
it hilarious that the ravager was going
to be missing his eye when he woke up
by the way when yondu eventually got his
new fin it was a nice nod the much
taller Mohawk fin that yeondu character
has in the comics star-lords new t-shirt
design for vol 2 is written in an alien
language that first appeared on a
keyboard display during the kiln prison
sequence in the first Guardians movie
the letter spell out gears shift which
according to Chris Pratt is the brand
name of a space candy and just below the
main logo on the t-shirt are some really
small words that translate a botanic
galaxy invention
Karen panic is actually the designer who
worked on these costume graphics for
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and her
previous credits include Captain America
the First Avenger the original song
guardians and fan o that plays at the
end of the movie is credited to the
sneakers featuring David Hasselhoff
Hasselhoff of course was referenced
multiple times in the movie and appeared
briefly when ego took on his appearance
however the name sneakers is actually an
easter egg - an aggressive race of
aliens who invaded numerous planets and
first appeared in issue 49 of the comic
tales of suspense in 1964 in that comic
who the watcher used them as a
cautionary tale and warned that the
alien ray for watching earth and waiting
for mankind to destroy itself with
nuclear weapons by the way the owner of
the iron Lotus the bar that you on doing
the Ravagers visit on contracts here is
a sneaker the creature tried to steal
the sovereigns batteries is called
Annapolis a beast that's new to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in volume 2
but the look of the a ballistic seems to
take inspiration from the creatures in
the comics called the many angled ones
the many angles ones are linked with a
cancer verse and like the Apple s they
often manifest themselves as Sharptooth
monstrosity with masses of tentacles
given the appearance of the creature in
this movie it'll be interesting to see
if it can traverse was buying new
creatures and storylines the guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 you'll have to pay
really close attention but there's a
brief cameo by actor Greg Henry if you
play grandpa quill in the 1st Guardians
movie in a scene on earth he's driving a
car with his friend and get
along by the huge blue blobs that
multiplies after ego activates his
seedlings to take over the galaxy by the
way also cameo in earlier in the scene a
James Gunn's parents who the older
couple who asked what the blob is as
they settle it on their phones the end
credits also have a little cameo by
Graham Park will who appears in a little
bubble as the credits roll there's also
a small cameo by Jeff Goldblum dancing
in another bubble during the credits at
ease with appearances Grand Master in
school Ragnarok plus there are cameos by
characters who appeared in the credit so
the first guardians of the galaxy movie
like cosmos of space dog and Howard the
Dirk who also appears briefly in this
movie during the scene on contracts eeeh
also watch the credits even more
carefully and you'll notice that some of
the cast and crew names replaced for a
few seconds with the words I am Groot
now whether any other cool Easter Egg
views botted in Gordon's the galaxy vol
2 and which were your favorite moments
in the movie be sure to comment and
subscribe for a chance to win one of
these Guardians the Galaxy prizes I've
got two fantastic hardback books from DK
the ultimate guide to the cosmic outlaws
which take an in-depth look at iconic
storylines and characters from the
comics plus I've got three cool
Guardians Funko pop vinyl figures to
give away to make sure you turn on your
notifications to get all my new
guardians videos and to find out if
you've won a prize if you enjoyed this
video I really appreciate you hitting
that thumbs up button and you can watch
more of my guardians of the galaxy vol 2
and Marvel videos right here thanks for
watching and see you next time you beat
a movie lovers